The X-Men Universe is still going strong,
with not just solo stories following some
of the most fan-favorite characters, but massive
event films calling on nearly every character
in the X-Men movies.
And as the stakes get higher, the action gets
more elaborate - which means more amazing
mistakes and unbelievable errors slip through
for fans to enjoy.
We've run down some of our favorites in our
latest rapid-fire dose of trivia, Know Your
Movies: 15 Most Shocking Mistakes From X-Men
Movies.
X-Men
Fans may never know why Wolverine's metal
claws and bone claws look so different, but
we know this much: audiences weren't supposed
to see the screws in them in the first movie.
Cyclops may have an awesome power, but he
needs to manually fire his optic blasts by
pressing his visor - except in the movie's
opening, when it fires a controlled blast
all by itself.
It turns out Magneto can't just control metal
- he can control time itself, going by the
reversed footage sold out by the exhaust flowing
back into a police cruiser's tailpipe.
Most comic fans have a hard time remembering
Iceman's real name - including his co-star,
Anna Paquin.
When the two meet on a school bench, the word
"Bobby" is heard, even though she's clearing
saying "Shawn," as in actor Shawn Ashmore.
X-Men 2
Watching Wolverine take a bullet to the head,
and then watching his body push it out is
unforgettable.
Until you realize his skull is made of the
world's toughest metal, meaning the bullet
wouldn't have had anywhere near enough flesh
to lodge in, and should have just ricocheted.
When Mystique tries to romance Wolverine pretending
to be Jean Grey, it's her scars that give
her away - scars made by his claws in the
first movie.
But the scars are now lined up vertically
along her stomach - not horizontally, like
they clearly were in the first movie.
Nightcrawler's teleporting helps him rescue
kidnapped children, but instead of filming
the scene twice, they did it once - which
means even before he BAMFs into the cell,
you can spot his silhouette in the shadows.
X-Men 3
Wolverine might heal, but apparently his clothes
do, too.
Judging by the bloody holes torn in his undershirt
by a pair of bone horns (1:06:00) - which
completely disappear later in the scene.
During the final battle on Alcatraz Island,
overhead images show the Golden Gate bridging
easily reaching from the shore.
That's because the island in the image is
actually way bigger, and closer than in real
life - Google it yourself.
Mutants have powers, but they can't all read.
Not Pyro anyway, who gets Multiple Man's cell
number wrong, despite the fact that he's standing
right in front of it.
X-Men: First Class
When Hank McCoy is teaching Banshee to use
his scream to fly, he gives an easy instruction.
Oh, make the sound waves travel faster than
sound, that totally makes sense.
Add another superpower to Magneto's list,
since he's able to not just throw an armed
guard into the air, but apparently keep him
flying into the stratosphere, since he never
drops back to Earth again.
He will be missed.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
The effects team of Days of Future Past painstakingly
recreated Robert F Kennedy Stadium in Washington,
down to the groundskeeper painting the baseball
diamond.
But nobody double checked the year: in 1973
the Senators had already become the Texas
Rangers, leaving it only for the NFL's Redskins.
The Paris Peace Accords play a major role
in the story, but the famous signing took
place in January of 1973 - but you won't find
any snow anywhere in the film.
Wolverine uses his bone claws to keep Magneto
from reading about those same Peace Accords
- but he wasn't missing much: the opening
paragraph is taken straight from the agreement's
Wikipedia page.
Those are some of our favorite mistakes, leaving
us wondering how they never got caught - and
adding another reason to rewatch the old movies,
as well as the new.
Which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and subscribe
to our channel to see what mistakes join the
rest with X-Men: Apocalypse.